Republicans are fed up with atom shift
secret impeachment hearings and now
they're doing something about it
furious Republican congressman fought
back by storming their way into a
closed-door interview with the latest
witness Republicans also hammering
Democrats for the total lack of
transparency behind those doors they
intend to overturn the results of an
American presidential election
what is that of shift trying to hide
what is happening here is not fair
there is no reason this should be down
in a tiny room within a room within a
skiff at the basement of the Capitol
that so Adam Schiff can control the
narrative can drive polling and can get
the vote that he wants which is to
impeach the president
all that is happening while the media
eats up the latest talking point
spoon-fed to them by the Democrats
check out this press endlessly repeating
that the testimony from the top diplomat
to Ukraine was quote devastating and
clear evidence of a quid pro quo
up ahead much more on this devastating
day for the Trump administration it's
devastating testimony really devastating
piece of evidence that's why this
testimony today was so devastating it's
devastating it's a smoking gun
devastating from a national security
perspective his testimony is devastating
that sounds like a quid pro quo directed
by the president is in fact a quid pro
quo to push for a quid pro quo there was
in fact a quid pro quo they very clear
quid pro quo that is a quid pro quo not
so fast
Republicans in the room say the diplomat
crumbled under questioning and there was
no evidence of a quid pro quo Juan don't
you think this would just clear
everything up if they just did this and
open yeah but it wouldn't be a
legitimate process why not
because you don't want to libel somebody
what if somebody says something is not
true or something in part you think it
would be illegitimate to hold a hearing
in public no you didn't ask me that you
said this impeachment inquiry that's
being done right now in private in other
words to allow people confidentiality
you make statements and then they can be
brought forward by the way quid pro quo
how can you not did you read what Bill
Taylor said bill Taylor who's a West
Point grad who served
Vietnam a Bush appointee ambassador in
places like Afghanistan Creek you think
he's a liar
I read his opening statement but we
didn't hear his is him under
cross-examination and that's what I
think Greg no but you're gonna write one
yeah there is no evidence of acquit we
can't even prove that because you don't
even have any people asking questions in
public here's his state but you can read
it Jesse in the state okay anybody can
make a statement
anybody can so you able to answer a
follow-up question which apparently he
did you think Taylor's a liar and I
don't know what he is one but I know I
don't know and you don't either
yeah but the president around the
presses I know that they're calling
people in secret and the Democrats are
leaking it I can read shame no you're
doing this behind closed door I am proud
that the press of the United States of
America can report on a legitimate
distinguished diplomats state it's all
leagues won and you know I think the
thing is the problem of the secret
testimony is that nobody should believe
it because it's it right off the bat it
stinks and here's the way I look at it
you all you need to know is you've got
to ask yourself a question you have
historically low unemployment you got
six point four million new jobs a
booming economy so far you have peace
and it's contagious one I'm sorry so
what is the establishment loser response
a secret anonymously driven coup which
is a gone by the media that to your
point that is the thing that I don't
understand there's only one explanation
for this because of the results of
Trump's White House so far they realize
they can't beat him so they need to
eliminate him so what they're do is that
are willing to divide and creative and
create division among a country as a
political weapon to solve their
political humiliation I have one
question for libertarians for leftists
true leftists and pacifists you now have
a president whose primary goal is not
spilling any more blood anywhere where
are you this is like the most
progressive foreign policy I've seen in
my life but are you gonna let the New
York Times you can let Hillary Clinton
or gonna let CNN and Adam Schiff
basically replace him with a Hillary pod
because they don't like him
after what he's doing that's pretty
freakin crazy
Dana what do you think about this you
know the Washington Post likes to say
democracy dies in the darkness I think
that arguing for transparency it usually
is your best argument especially with
the media because we Revere the First
Amendment right so the transparency
thing is good the stunt today of going
down you know the president said I want
my the Republicans to get tougher
so that and they'll win the new cycle on
that today like they'll be able to drive
the news but when the majority the House
Democrats have the gavel they're they're
not affected by the transparency
argument they just keep rolling down
until they see something in their
polling or in their focus groups or the
pressure from their constituents gets to
a fever pitch on transparency they're
probably not going to change it the
other thing is I think I feel like the
goalposts
for both sides are moving so much but
even if there was to say like there was
a quid pro quo I'm pretty sure everyone
be like okay fine yeah who cares who
cares because that's what people do Dana
correct what well it's it's like I want
you to check I want you to check out
your corruption before we give you all
this money that's what that's what his
job is great sorry I mean ever Greg
that's not the quid pro quo here was
something for the president something
like I tell you dirt yes litical
eruptions no no no no you got a look at
this he was talking about corruption if
it could 2016 corruption look into it
I'm sure Joe bide also won there there
is no quid pro quo because the
Ukrainians didn't even know that any of
the money was being with us after so
we'll play some sound from the
Republicans on this and you can react
the mainstream media reporting that he
provided evidence of a of a quid pro quo
involving military aid is false neither
he or any other witness has provided
testimony that the Ukrainians were aware
that military aid was being withheld you
can't have a quid pro quo with no quo
the truth is is that in two minutes John
Ratcliffe destroyed this witness there's
no quid pro quo after so far you know I
find it interesting because you know
reading through the timeline they had
the conversation the phone conversation
Trump insulin scan July and there's
reports that the White House was holding
back these fundings the funds themselves
weren't actually going to be used until
September October unless Solinsky made
some public declaration which by the way
never actually happened yet the funds
did go there so you know I have a lot of
questions when it comes to the quid pro
quo you know and unfortunately the lack
of transparency my questions aren't
being answered Adam Schiff is running
such a tight ship with the closed-door
policy here yet he's allowing the leaks
he's allowing this narrative to build up
full of like inflated verbage and I just
think it continues to divide the country
and that just seems to be their number
one goal right now is massive division
for 2020 election and I'm tired of all
this posturing just for election
purposes yeah I think that one after a
while if you're gonna continue to do
this in the dark and secret so the
country can't know why the president is
being impeached people are gonna be fed
up with it I think this is gonna do
long-term damage here oh let me get this
straight you don't know why the
president's being impeached you can't
have any evidence even seen by
Republicans they can't even see
transcripts they're actually threatening
to withhold my letter let me get the
people that are testifying you don't
know why the president's being impeached
you want to see the full evidence you
listen to witness that's the best
ammonia that's the that's the legitimate
constitutional process that they would
hold in a you think it's legitimate line
close doors they are absolutely anything
this is legitimate one I just told you I
do and the second thing to tell you is
that you will come out and then you will
say oh my gosh why are they presenting
it this way this is unfair dwindle and
come out but not it's going to come out
in a month or so but
you say this it's the Senate that should
be worrying you Jesse because right now
we see reporting that says I think
there's a daily call or somebody you
know did a poll of all the people in the
Senate forget to poll the American
people who think this is legitimate
there were only seven senators who said
they're not open to the inquiry
impeaching and removing the pie look
worried where do you see this going well
the shift will continue to call these
witnesses like because everything is so
polarized each side thinks that they're
winning and there are Republicans who
think that absolutely you impeach
domfront not that impeachment does not
mean that he's not going to be president
anymore Clinton was impeached and his
polling numbers went up his popularity
went up if you probably had a chance to
run for a third term who knows what
would happen although I don't know I'm
not saying there are Republicans who
truly believe this is helping them then
there are Democrats who think this that
they have to do this in order to try to
beat back again fight back against their
base who is frustrated because they want
to say how are you holding the president
accountable in the meantime especially
kind of interesting there's reporting
today that Pelosi steam and the Trump
White House are still working on their
plan as whatever you think about the
lowering of the drug prices at least
their policy proposal which I don't
think it's great prescription but
they're still moving forward on that and
the trade deal the u.s. MCA apparently
is still on track as well so maybe it's
possible that they could actually still
get things done and continue with
impeach are you talking about walking
and chewing gum at the same time that's
a great cliche a great analogy I can't
believe I thought of it is crooked
Hillary about to make a comeback how
close Clinton is to a 2020 rematch with
Trump up next